(hip hop music)
- Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Orlando, what up?
(audience cheering loudly)
Morning, morning.
Sit, let's do this.
- [Female] I love you, Gary!
- I love you so much!
(audience screaming loudly)
Good morning.
- [Male] I love you, too!
- Thanks, dude!
I want to, I want to get
some things in this morning.
I want to talk about a
couple of core things.
I want to talk about two
very opposite things.
One, probably more mindset, just kind of,
you know it's funny.
When I think about motivation and mindset,
they don't come natural to me.
It's not what kind of gets me going.
It really goes into a place
more of just strategy.
To me it's just practical.
If you're actually optimistic
or if you're in the right place,
you're able to do the actions needed
to get the results that
you want so I want to talk
a little bit about strategy.
I think some will take it
into motivation and mindset.
That's fine and I'm
thrilled but it's strategy.
AKA, let's just get, actually
I can make this very quick.
We are just completely
in this incredibly place
of unlimited options.
I just struggle with people's
inability to have perspective
on where they sit in opportunity
in a 7.7 billion-person world.
If you are sitting in
this arena this morning,
your rank amongst the 7.7
billion people in the world,
when it comes to opportunity,
is fucking ridiculous.
(audience cheering loudly)
I have the privilege of being
a well member of a non-profit
called Charity Water
and I highly recommend
you take a look at it.
If you actually, whatever
you complained about
in the last 48 hours,
if you understood that
there are millions of people
who don't have access to fresh water,
who literally woke up this
morning and walked seven miles
one way and then back to create some level
of fresh fucking water for their family,
when that shit was literally
accessible to you in the sink
in your bathroom, you fucking complain?
You are fucking out of your mind.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I literally feel that so much
of what I'm able to accomplish
or the happiness I have, and honestly,
fuck a focus group of one.
When I look at thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands
of other people who are happy,
forget about Benz's and
shoes and homes and planes,
the ROI of life is not
money, it's be happy.
When I look at the people
that I see that are happy,
regardless of their
income levels or success
or fame or notoriety or money,
so much of that is completely predicated
on the fact that either their
parenting or circumstance
helped them have actual perspective
to what the hell is going on here.
I will tell you this, my number one thing,
probably on the back of
the fact that my mom,
who had a difficult life of
losing her mom when she was five
and growing up in Soviet
Russia and plenty of things,
being poor when we came to America,
the fact that that woman
never complained once,
probably had, and I mean once.
I lived an entire life
where I watched my mother
live her life knowing her circumstance
and never complained once, of course,
that had a huge impact on
my inability or tolerance
for complaining when I know
that the tens of thousands
of people in this room
have the ability to do
whatever the hell they want
because, oh by the way,
not only were you blessed
to be living in America,
not only were you blessed with
a million other variables,
but a lot of things that we talk about,
and I'm so happy so many things
have popped up in culture
where we talk about
unconscious bias or privilege,
and that's so good and I'm so glad
we're having those conversations,
but the privilege that
everybody in this room has
that your great grandparents didn't have,
your great great grandparents didn't have,
your great great great
grandparents didn't have
is regardless of how much debt you have,
or responsibilities, or
I have to feed my kids
or put clothes on backs,
or whatever your thing is,
debt or responsibilities, or most likely,
you bought too much shit you didn't need
and now you have to work
to pay for that bullshit.
(audience rumbling)
Right?
Because so many people, I love
the people that buy a home
that has four extra rooms
that they never fucking use.
(audience chuckling)
Then they have to keep a
job that they fucking hate
to pay for a house that has four bedrooms
that they never fucking use.
(audience applauding)
I know, my guy.
(audience cheering loudly)
Facts.
But the great privilege
that all of us have
is no matter how tough it feels
or what kind of golden handcuffs you have
or the pressure that you feel,
the fact that everybody here can eat shit
from eight in the morning
to 7:00 pm to pay their dues
and still come home and have this thing,
this phone is more
powerful, technology-wise,
than the computers that Ronald Reagan had
to run the free world.
This thing, while you
lay in bed from 7:00 pm
to two in the morning is
your gateway to get out of
the thing that you complain about,
yet we'd rather watch fucking
entire seasons of Friends
again on Netflix
(audience laughing)
or go on Twitter and
complain about some dumb shit
instead of, if you leave with anything
from my talk this morning,
there's only one word that I like
and that's accountability.
How many people here have a company,
how many here manage or have
a company where they have
one or more employees?
Raise your hand, raise it high.
Amazing.
Good news.
If you ever complain about an employee,
it's your fucking fault.
(audience chuckling)
You hired them.
You could literally walk
over and be like, hey Sarah,
you're fired, asshole.
(audience laughing loudly)
You could.
I am remarkably stunned by
the lack of accountability
in our society.
News alert.
Russia, Russia didn't
go in the booth with you
and pull the level so stop
blaming Facebook, assholes.
(audience screaming and cheering)
We, here's one that you
won't clap up as much,
everybody's shitting on millennials,
you fucking parented them, dick face!
(audience laughing loudly)
They're so entitled
because you entered them
into a baseball league that gave trophies
to eighth place teams, dick face!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Everything wrong at Vayner Media,
anything that ever happens,
any piece of content,
anything that ever happens in my life,
100 fucking percent is my fault.
(audience cheering)
Let me tell you what
happens with accountability.
You get real happy.
When you feel that there's no other source
controlling your shit,
all of a sudden it gets happier.
Your ego and your insecurity
doesn't want to take the L,
you don't want to admit
that you fucked up.
Because for some reason,
so many of you are living your lives
based on other people's opinions
and that is crippling you.
So many of the actions in this room,
if you're waking up this early
to come to this kind of
event, I know off the bat,
in the beginning, every fucking
person here has a percentage
from 10% to 100% of living
their lives based on
other people's opinions.
That, to me, is what
I want to get to zero.
If I could actually get you to 1%-2%
of living on other people's opinions,
you would shit your fucking
pants on how happy you would be.
(audience cheering)
You would.
No, there's an unbelievable
liberating feeling
when you can look at your
mom and say, mom, listen,
I know you're miserable but
I'm done with this shit,
fuck you.
(audience laughing and cheering)
By the way, I just hope
everybody understands,
because I know plenty of
you don't know who I am
and things of that nature, it's
not fun for me to say that.
I don't want to disrespect your mom
that brought you into this world.
I get it.
I just know that through
the tens of thousands
of direct messages and
emails that I'm getting
every single week, that
so many people's struggles
or not making themselves
happy is so predicated
on five to seven people in their lives
that they don't have the ability
to have an actual honest,
transparent conversation
about what that person's doing
to them and the standards
for perfection or judgment
that they deploy on them
is affecting their behavior
and I just, here's what I fear.
I feel like so many of you do things,
especially with parents,
because you don't want to upset
them or have confrontations
in the short-term without
realizing that that's going to
lead to 50 years of regret and resentment.
I'd rather you have
fights with your parents
for a couple of years
and then actually have
a good relationship than have
a shitty one in perpetuity.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I know.
Literally, do you know
how many people here
are not executing,
and I'm going to get into
social strategy in a second,
do you know how many of you do not execute
on social media strategies
properly because you're worried
that when you post
something that sixpants44
says you're ugly and then you cripple
and then you don't do shit?
(audience laughing)
Literally there's some anonymous
comment of, oh, by the way,
by the way, if somebody, let's just,
Orlando, can we do something
here on the record?
On the record!
On the record, if somebody takes
a minute to leave a comment
that's negative on your account,
they took the time out of their lives
to try to drag you down and shit on you,
don't be sad for you, be sad for them.
(audience applauding loudly)
People are like, Gary, how do
you deal with all that hate?
I deal with that hate easily.
I look at the comment and they're
like, you're full of shit,
you suck, and I legitimately
process in my head like, fuck,
that person's life must suck shit.
(audience laughing)
The thought that I would
ever spend one second
to go to somebody's
fucking Instagram account,
consume the content,
and then say, you suck,
is so fucking foreign to me.
My friends, negativity
can lead at halftime,
kindness always wins the game.
(audience cheering loudly)
Don't get it twisted.
With that all being
said, let me tell you why
I'm so passionate this morning.
I am blown away that I know 99% of you,
regardless of how deep you're in,
by the way, it's 100% including me,
we are not taking advantage of how big
this technology revolution is.
This internet thing is way
bigger than we can comprehend
because we're living in it.
How many people here are
over 40, raise your hands.
Amazing.
Let's clap it up for the over-40 crowd.
(audience applauding)
How many people here are under 30?
Let's clap it up for the youngsters.
Alright, under 30, under 30,
you're not going to believe
this but us old fuckers,
we lived most of our childhood
without the internet.
(audience laughing)
And it was fucking crazy!
Let me tell you some stories, kids.
Let me tell you how I
tried to use to meet up
with my friends at the mall.
You would talk during school
and you'd be like, yo Ricky,
okay, 4:30 at the fountain
by fucking Macy's, got it?
(audience laughing)
Now, here's where shit
got really fucked up.
This is where I love
when everyone's like, oh,
I hate all this technology,
the old days were better.
Was it?
Because I recall that when
I would go to the mall
and can't wait to see Ricky to
go play fucking arcade games
at the mall,
but there was traffic,
or his mom was late,
and I'd be at the fountain at 4:30
and after about 15 minutes
I'd have to give up and leave
and then at the next day
at school he'd be like,
where were you? I was like,
by the fountain at Macy's.
He's like, fuck, I was by
the fountain at KB Toys.
(audience laughing)
Kids under 30, we used
to not find each other.
(audience laughing)
We literally couldn't find each other.
We have an incredibly
ability in society to fear
the current and the future and
put the past on a pedestal.
We put the past on a pedestal
and we shit on the current and the future.
That is legitimately why
a far enormous percentage
of people here will not be able to succeed
because you shit on this.
You underestimate what's
actually happening.
Let me tell you one thing that
connects every person here.
From the rafters up there, what up, Rick.
(audience cheering)
It takes like an hour
for it to come up there.
You're like, yo!
I'm like talking, yo.
The one thing that connects everyone here
regardless of you're
winning, you're losing,
company, employee, entrepreneur,
the one thing from coast to coast
that connects every person
here is the one asset
that we should all be
chasing is attention.
Before you achieve anything,
whatever the hell you came here for,
when you go and output to
try to create your business,
run for mayor, raise
money for a non-profit,
no matter what you do, no matter
what you try to accomplish
when you leave this conference,
the one thing that you should be chasing
is people's attention.
Before you can accomplish
selling a sneaker or a cookie
or a t-shirt or insurance
or whatever you do,
you need somebody's
attention to tell them.
Then your message has to be
on-point enough to commit them
into doing what you'd like.
Attention, my friends, is the asset.
Nothing else is important
to me besides attention.
The reason I've always
adapted to new content
and new platforms, the internet
itself, email, YouTube,
Google AdWords, Facebook,
Twitter, podcasting, all of it,
the reason I've always done
well with that is my religion
above anything else is
where is the attention today
and potentially tomorrow,
not what worked yesterday.
So many people.
- [Male] Gary!
- Yes.
- [Male] You're right.
- I know I'm right.
(audience laughing)
That's why I'm up here, dick.
(audience laughing loudly)
My friends, I love you, Carl.
Listen, listen.
Attention is the asset.
It's why everything changes
when attention changes.
The reason people,
the reason there's so much
happening in society globally,
not just America, I love
that people don't understand.
People are so underedu-,
Americans suck shit at knowing
what's going on in the world.
We're so insular.
We are.
You don't understand,
what's happening in America
is happening all over the world.
It's called nationalism.
What's happening in America
is happening in India,
what's happening in America
is happening in many places
in the world.
The reason this is happening
is because information is changing.
The way we consume
information is changing.
Amazon growing and
going to destroy Walmart
has the same thing to
do with the reason why
different points of view
and opinions happen.
There's so much happening
and it's amazing.
I actually think it's
amazing what's happening
because we're exposing so much.
So much is now getting shed light on
because the media's changing.
In that macro trend,
you need to figure out
your micro opportunity.
You need to understand, for example,
I don't care who you are in this room,
if you're not buying
Facebook and Instagram ads
for your ambition, and I'm
saying the word ambition
not business, because maybe
you want to be the president
of the PTA and that will cost you
literally $180 on Facebook if
you know what you're doing.
You have to understand that
no matter what your opinion is
of technology, it doesn't
care about your opinion
and it's going to
continue to do its thing.
So many of you are not
harnessing the power of this
out of ideological points
of view and being lazy
to not put in the 50 hours of homework
to actually be good at it.
You know how many people
here have run $1000
on Facebook ads, it didn't work,
and are sitting in this
conference right now
with the opinion that
Facebook ads don't work?
We have to put in the work.
This is a remarkable time.
Let me tell you why I did
not make content that much
from 2011 to 2014 on the
internet for the people
that have been following me.
It was because there was
nothing remarkable for me
at that moment that made
me compelled to communicate
at a high level.
I sit here this morning and
stand here in front of you
with regret on one of
the great accomplishments
of my career.
I walked into my dad's
liquor store business
that was doing four million dollars a year
and very quickly grew it to $30, $40,
$50 million dollars in revenue on the back
of Google AdWords and email
marketing in the late '90s
and early 2000s when nobody
understood what that was.
But I grew it to a $60
million dollar business
and the truth is, my friends,
it should have been $200 million.
I didn't spend enough on Google AdWords
when I had the best hand.
When I knew Google was
special, I spent 50%, 60%, 70%
of my money when it should have been 95%.
But I kept doing direct
mail and I kept doing
WineSpectator.com and I did the Star.
How many people from Jersey in here?
(audience cheering)
What's up?
I did the Star fucking Ledger
ad and I did all that shit
because I didn't understand
how historically special
that moment was on Google.
That Google was this unbelievable platform
that we would continue
to use 20 years later
to search information
and that the ads on it
were misunderstood at first
for how powerful they were,
thus, they were underpriced.
Amazon was the biggest
spender on Google AdWords
the first five to six years.
They used Google to become Amazon.
I know that right this second,
as we sit here this morning,
that Facebook ads and Instagram
ads are that same thing
that I lived through in the early 2000s.
I know it because I've
watched what it's doing for me
and for every business I'm associated with
whether it's a client or
whether it's a start-up
or somebody that emails
me, oh, 40, 50, 60, 80,
100 times a week telling me
that their business sucked shit.
Then they finally really
started listening,
started really executing,
and good things miraculously happened.
How many people here have run Facebook ads
and it's done something
good for their business?
Raise your hand.
Actually, stand up, stand up.
I want people to feel this visual.
I want everybody who's
standing and sitting
to understand why I'm doing this.
Not only have these people seen success,
I promise you, and take
note of who's standing
and if you don't know them,
ask them during intermission,
thank you for standing, you can sit now.
I will tell you that if
they tell you the truth,
they will admit that
they're not even that great
at Facebook.
I'm being serious.
It is such underpriced attention
that even average execution,
even average pictures
and videos and words are getting results
because the attention is so underpriced.
Please, if you leave this
conference with anything
other than fuck, I want to
go all in on accountability
because that's going to get my mind right
and allow me to do shit, other than that,
you have to go all in on
Facebook and Instagram.
The pricing is so remarkable,
it is so underpriced,
and all it will take is
20-30 hours, listen to me.
I'm telling you, I'm
telling you, and by the way,
I want everybody to know
why I'm about to go into
this little three minute rant.
This is not me being a good guy.
This is very selfish.
D-Rock, where you at?
(audience yelling)
Hey, D-Rock, let's hear it for D-Rock.
(audience cheering loudly)
D-Rock, can you move and come here
because I'm about to go into this rant
not because I'm going to be a great guy
and want you to like win.
I want to be selfish.
I'm about to rant and
tell you on the record
that 98% of you, Orlando,
99% of you, Orlando,
are going to regret this day
for the rest of your life.
Let me tell you why.
Because I'm about, and right
now I'm setting up this moment,
I'm about to spew something
real heavy for four minutes,
I'm going to put pressure on you to do it,
because for 80% of the
99%, if you were to do it,
you will see results.
Yet, miraculously, 98%
of you will do nothing
that I'm about to say.
Because you're going to be
pumped as fuck right now,
right, you're going to be
like, yes, I'm going to,
he's right, I'm going to fucking do it,
Sally, I'm fucking do it!
(audience laughing loudly)
- [Male] Do it!
- But next Tuesday, something
bad's going to happen
and because your mind's not
right, you're going to dwell
and it's going to create inaction.
You're not going to do it.
I'm doing this selfishly
because I'm literally going to
take this video, this
moment, I'm going to post it
in seven years to people
that live in Orlando
and a 100 mile radius of it.
You're going to watch it in 2025.
You're going to see it
and be like motherfucker!
(audience laughing loudly)
- [Female] Not me, Gary!
- I hope so, darling.
If you do me one favor,
and you got to go see
Robert and Tony, and I
wish I was speaking last
because I would literally
tell you fuck faces
to stand up now and leave.
(audience laughing)
Because nothing in the next 10
minutes that I'm going to say
is anywhere close to as valuable
as what I'm about to say.
Go home and spend 30-50
hours, which is zero time.
It's absolutely no fucking time
in the scheme of your life.
Spend 30-50 hours and learn
how to be a practitioner
in running the ads, aka targeting people.
Targeting real estate
agents that live in Kansas
and making some reference.
The unlimited nature of
the targeting capabilities
of Facebook and Instagram is overwhelming.
Literally, fans of the New York Jets,
literally every brand
could get my business
if they ran ads against
fans of the New York Jets
and then the video and
picture was contextual
to the New York Jets.
They would get my business.
Learn how to target people.
Read, by the way, don't buy
some bullshit $9000 eBook.
No.
It's free.
YouTube, Facebook, Google,
you'll get free information,
there's tons of it.
Go run ten, $30, $80 at a
time against your picture
and video and written words
on Facebook and Instagram
and sit back and marvel at how
much the results can happen.
But rest assured this, if you
target somebody perfectly,
a stay at home mom in
Missouri that's into fashion
and you've got a fashion
stay at home mom product,
if you target it perfectly,
please still know
that the picture and the
video that you put out
is the variable if it will be successful.
We target perfectly or
extremely well, best in class,
consistently, right?
Vayner, my team, blah blah blah.
But the variables of our
success are remarkably different
based on how good the
picture and the video is.
My friends, right this
minute, late August 2018,
in your face, in your face,
is one of the great business
attention opportunities
of our lives.
It will go away.
We will wake up in a decade
and Facebook and Instagram
won't be winning.
MySpace is not winning anymore.
Shit changes.
MTV's not winning anymore.
Right?
Shit changes.
Our attention moves.
Running ads on MTV in 1984
to teenager, great idea.
Today, fucking terrible.
Running Facebook and Instagram
ads today, and by the way,
I don't want to hear, well,
my customers aren't on it.
Let me give you a little
news alert everybody.
Fifty to 80-year olds on Facebook,
over indexing and converting
better than anybody else.
Wow, I was right.
You know why?
First of all, all of them are on it.
Your grandma's on fucking Facebook.
(audience chuckling)
Spewing her politics either
to the left or to the right.
The other amazing things about
really fucking old people,
they go really slow.
(audience laughing loudly)
Which means they consume that shit.
The fucking teenager is like, phf phf phf!
Like fuck!
Grandma Ester, slow as fuck.
(audience laughing loudly)
If you can go very basic on me
and understand a couple of truths,
truth number one, attention
is the ultimate asset.
It's how everything good ever happens.
It's how everything bad ever happens.
It's attention.
- [Female] Gary!
- Yes?
- [Female] Right here.
You made me stand up, you talk
about attracting attention.
I've got your attention.
I'm going to do all the
dishes at lunch today
for the chance to sit
with you at your table.
- Done.
(audience applauding loudly)
Nobody else be rude or
I'll punch you in the face.
(audience laughing)
Listen, listen to me.
Attention is the number one asset.
You have to figure out how to
produce audio, written words,
pictures, and videos
for Facebook, Twitter,
LinkedIn, Instagram.
The reason to watch my content
is not for me to motivate you
on Instagram, it's for you
to watch what I'm doing
in getting people's attention.
You should be consuming my content.
You could fi-.
Listen, some people it takes
three years to figure out
what I'm up to, right, other
people it takes one day, right?
That's fine.
I don't care about that.
The only reason I'd ever
want people to continue
to follow my content
is not for my message.
It's super basic, do
the right thing, dick.
Right?
That's my message.
Cool, let's all move on.
The reason to watch my content is to watch
how I'm manifesting and creating content
on all these platforms
contextually to the platform
and then for you to replicate it
for whatever your mission is.
Attention.
Number two, just an enormous truth.
If you let somebody else's opinion,
whether your spouse, your
boss, your mom, your aunt,
your best friend, if
you genuinely, genuinely
are living your only
life, which oh by the way,
by modern scientific terminology
is 400 trillion to one,
if you even could comprehend
how ridiculous it is
that we are even alive,
like literally your mom
could have gotten up
and got another glass of wine.
(audience laughing)
Like, literally.
Like do you understand how ludicrous it is
that you have a life?
There's nothing mathematically
in life that can happen
that is more ridiculous than
the fact that you've got one.
You're more likely to get
struck by lightning 14 times
than have a life.
Yet, everybody's walking around here
like we fucking deserve it.
Like we're coming back.
Do you know how many
people here are living life
like they're coming fucking back?
Listen, I don't want to
get into religions and shit
but you're not coming back, dick.
(audience laughing)
And even if you are, you're
going to be fucking like a rhino
or a tree or a rock.
(audience laughing)
Imagine if that's ac-, by the way,
I'm going to go so weird for a minute,
imagine if we actually did
come back but it had to be
a physical object.
Could image literally being
a tree and sitting there
and being like fuck, I used to be a human.
(audience laughing loudly)
If you are living your only life,
based on your older sister's
point of view, or guys,
please, please deeply
understand how truthful
misery loves company is.
Do you how much of your
mom's advice is predicated
on her resentment and regret
on the advice her mom gave you?
And even though she was so pissed at her,
she's doing the same shit to you?
This is real talk.
Please do not live your
life based on your mom,
definitely not sallypants44
in the Facebook comments.
I fucking hate sallypants44!
(audience chuckling)
And most of all, please
stop buying dumb shit
to look good in front of
people that you don't like
in the first place.
(audience cheering and applauding loudly)
And most of all, and this is
super contextual to this event,
faking it til you make it is very 1987.
We now live in a world
where transparency has won.
Speak the truth.
Do the right thing.
Kindness is cool.
Truth is cool.
Don't act like you've made it.
Talk about the journey
of trying to make it.
Authenticity is what rules.
In 2006 when I stood up
and I started talking
and I cursed, it was
fundamentally unacceptable.
I missed out on 90% of my opportunities.
People didn't like it
but I couldn't help it.
I'm from Jersey, this is how I talk.
I know that there are still
people in this audience
that don't love it and I
respect that tremendously.
But let me tell you something.
In 2018, wearing jeans
and a t-shirt and cursing
at a public event is a hell
of a lot more acceptable
than it was 12 years ago.
I stuck to my truth.
I worked every day from 20-30,
I worked every day from
20-30 and never said a word.
I wasn't a 20-year old life
coach, I wasn't any of that.
I worked and actually
built a huge business,
built businesses, actually
invested in Facebook
and Twitter in 2006.
I actually did it and then
after 20 years of doing it,
then I started talking
about it a little bit.
Faking it til you make
it is the great flaw
of this generation.
Please don't do it.
Please stop listening
to anybody but yourself.
Please eliminate negativity from your life
because if you want to really win,
it is absolutely by
reinforcing positivity.
So get real quiet in here,
get real selective about who
you're spending time with,
and most of all, understand
why I'm pushing you
into all this foofy foofy shit.
The reason I'm pushing you
into all of this kindness
and gratitude and compassion
and all this good shit
is once you get there, then
you can put in the 13, 14, 16,
then your mind, do you know
how quiet it is up here?
Do you know how quiet
it is right here for me?
I can't hear it.
By the way, pay very close attention
to what I'm about to say.
Not just the negative, the positive too.
When I post something,
when somebody's like, Gary,
you walk on water, you're
the best, you're a genius,
quite.
I don't hear that either.
I'm on my mission doing my
thing and when it gets quiet,
you get fast.
The reason I can work 17 hours a day
is because I'm not spending 15 hours a day
dwelling or looking back.
Guys, nobody gives a shit
that your brother stole $1000
from you six years ago.
Get over it, dick.
Forward, forward, forward.
Mindset.
All of that leads to one thing.
If you do not become a
practitioner of how to communicate
on the social networks of
today, you are 100% irrelevant.
Don't like it?
Tough.
Figure it out, execute it.
This is on the record, I
don't want you to regret it
in seven years and I
promise you in seven years,
whether it's Facebook or Twitter
or Schmitter and Hastebook,
I will fucking find your
attention and I will shit on you
for not doing something about it today!
(audience cheering loudly)
Thank you, Orlando!
(hip hop music)